you came into our homes for seven years
as a force
on the real if you're not gonna eat it
i'm gonna eat it
you have to make sure that you do your
research about what
you bring to the table i was like what
the hell what's the poison
i'm just curious what is life like now
without the show
well i mean i the girls will always be a
part of my family
so in a way i feel like i haven't yeah
may not be
physically in front of the camera i mean
i had
i'll just talk to you know most of the
girls
just just recently so we will be a
family
for forever so i feel like i'm it's not
it's weird to say but i feel like
they're we're still
i'm still there has it not hit you yet
is it strange when you're flipping
channels or you see clips online and
you know tamara's face is not there no i
don't know why uh
no because i i am an extended part of
who
who they are at you know like i said i i
still talk to the producers
they became they became friends i still
talk to the girls
i support the girls still individually
uh is there a group chat is there a
group chat
no i do it i do it individually because
they're all they're all doing their own
thing
uh genie is really busy right now with
dancing with the stars i
i told her i i saw her i i know
adrian is doing a show on fox right now
lonnie um we talked like
she was she just texted me and was like
how are you doing in quarantine
and garcelle i've known for years i mean
she is amazing she's beautiful she's
lovely
she's twins so we we have we have we
have talked
actually i've known her throughout
throughout my life
so we were on the wb together
and she's always been she's always been
fantastic so i just you know i
i support them i i also you know
and they support me that's what's
awesome they support me the sisterhood
it has to be
yes ah so freaking lutely and in life
there
there are journeys and you have you have
you have your different your different
chapters
right so are you watching the show do
you keep up with it
girl i'm not watching any i'm so busy i
am a i am a
working mom and i uh
i'm actually producing the show the
movie that i'm doing right now so i'm in
the midst of casting
and my kids go to school virtually yeah
i haven't watched
i haven't watched pretty much anything
right now
i haven't i want to move on now you're
full-time living in napa working on your
your vineyard and this amazing family
that you've created what does life look
like for you
now in this next chapter there's one
word i can think of
and it's peace i
have peace i have peace because i'm with
my family
and my family rejuvenates me so being
around my family being there for my
children they're at an age right now
where they want
mommy around um you know i like i'm a
hands-on
parent i know i like you know to to
help them whether it's in you know
soccer dance
obviously it's pre-coveted um but we
still do those things
at home with school with with homework
and we started you know my husband has
had the winery for years with this
family but we
are now in control over it it's pretty
awesome when your father-in-law is like
here you want this and you're like what
talk about a dream
it is seriously a dream i go to work
and i feel like i have found my
retirement job
like it doesn't feel like yeah i'm
actually doing my retirement job as we
speak
meaning working in the tasting room and
stuff and i enjoy it but i haven't given
up hollywood i will be in hollywood
as long as i'm having fun how about that
that's a perfect response
thank you use the word peace was it hard
to find that peace when you had your
life
in hollywood no it's just it's just for
me the balance
i feel like there's a time in your life
and i've been so
grateful to have worked for so long in
hollywood
i'm now at an age right now where i can
say
wait i want to spend this much time
doing this
and this much time doing that
so the choices that i'm making right
now the number one question i say is
well am i going to have enough time with
my family that would travel back and
forth
my family you know is is up there and
being away from them
for you know a period of time and trap
it could be it could be stressful
of course and so listen i mean i'm
curious if your kids played a role
in the decision to be full-time in napa
because
you know a lot of celebrities they they
raise their kids in hollywood and yeah
go many different ways no one knows
better than you 100
i i grew up in texas
i grew up in hawaii i loved my childhood
and what my husband and i we want to
teach again you'll hear me say balance a
lot right
i want to teach my children balance i
love the life
that they're living right now in the
sense that it's the country life
if they want to live that city life when
they get older
yes they will they will you know run to
it i want them to have
a sense of normalcy um not that they
couldn't have it in l.a but then again
they know what their mom and dad do
now they know that mom is on tv
like they love twitches they want to see
everything i'm in they love
sister sister but at the same time i
want to know that other side as well
what does the next five to ten years
look like for you is it acting is it
posting
is it wine is it being a full-time mom
and maybe putting the other stuff on the
back burner
you you actually said everything that i
want to do
in the next five ten years that resume
yes it is my resume so i absolutely
love everything about the winery it is
very inclusive
anybody and everybody is welcomed in
that tasting room and that is what
it is that's what it's known for i love
acting
acting is like oh gosh it's like my
my my number one like love i
loved doing my talk show i i you know it
was great
i learned a lot about myself about
people the importance of
of your voice and not being afraid to
you know
vocalize your opinion because you never
know who is out there that truly needs
to hear your words
right now i'm focusing on my family
and and acting october 10th
world mental health day how will you be
honoring the day
through exercise it always helps me
mentally
and physically and i'm proud to say i'm
one of those that
lost like 16 pounds during the
quarantine but
i like to do things that make me think
i'm not working out
but i am i've been doing zumba for years
i
i did zumba to get ready for my wedding
i um
did zumba to get back in shape after you
know having
my kids and you know we're talking about
mental health day i always talk about
the importance of making sure that you
take care of yourself
mentally not only you know physically
don't don't forget about that i want to
know
what is the goal where are you at in the
journey and what is the regimen
people who have followed my my weight
loss journey they have realized and this
is
in real life i've gone up i've gone down
i've gone up
i've gone down and the reason why i was
yo-yoing
is because i was on a bad diet
or i was there's this there's this diet
called the amino
uh diet where you take like drops
i was doing all of that you lose the
weight quickly
but it wasn't sustainable for my life
i know i can't cut out carbs or i can't
cut out
sugar for the rest of my life i believe
god made food
and the way i see it is there aren't any
bad foods
you just have to make sure that you eat
it in a very
balanced way so instead of
eating a hamburger and fries every
single day
choose a day and mine is fridays because
it's like friday
now i will tell you i am aware i will
not have the same body
that i had before i had kids meaning
my hips have spread i've got a little
loose skin here and there
but i want to get close to my
pre-pregnancy weight and i am about
nine pounds away i'm so impressed by you
it's all the dancing and it's like
making those mindful decisions that we
don't have to do the excess and the
indulging every day
but damn you enjoy that burger on a
[Music]
friday
you